like we've read that step five times I
don't understand uh hi guys I'm Lea hi
I'm destiny
hello oh okay we are making origami
sober yes we are going to be trying to
do origami
chelated have you ever have you ever
made origami before I have never
successfully but I have tried on a scale
of 1 to 10 I met a good like six private
have six I'm like climbing slowly so I
might like a 7.2 right now Wow let's get
to folding let's do it
you don't do the cup or the Samurai
helmet let's do the cup Cup we're not
doing this that is what we're not gonna
do crane Swan wait we already what
Street a crane this one I know that's
right a crane has long legs I think or
along neck long neck like a crane long
neck like an actual cream the burger the
burger shouldn't burn or help there's no
construction Swan a crane of the Swan Oh
what is this one a piano and the house
you know step number one fold the paper
how like a triangle that is what it
looks like oh yeah
step number one you fold this in half we
are really killing it look at that it
was really good we know instructions
that's cool
fold the paper I stepped in the gym fold
over and then open again
what does that mean fold the paper let's
just follow their arrows just like fold
up it's weird it's like two lines like
it's like of down then up this is where
I usually give it I'm gonna start doing
origami after this are you I think it
sounds uh hey fold over okay in with the
whole day am i where I'm really lost far
enough away let's just try it if it's
terrible look at all the paper we have
okay now we have folded this into four
parts yes so piano cat house the couch
yeah no penthouse
that love it number four we open and
flatten whoa what is that this is where
it's okay so we're gonna go like this
this is the line there okay so just fold
that okay you know what it is what I
think we just fold it but not actually
do anything with it so I bend it yeah
then what is this one then then it's
like go back ah okay you got okay okay
you go like this I'm warm
I'm Lea I like Mike this is where we
need to be you were put me up go back
the pictures don't tell a lot of things
this is where we show okay so looks like
we close we do close my eyes what Oh
what
whoa wait that I really need to take a
little I think I think I understand I'm
gonna try something okay fold this all
the way to the corner you know why I'm
shouting that's what it says
it sounds like look it doesn't say
anything but it points I just don't
understand we get from here to here same
it looks like wait I have to all like
really look at it okay I fold him oh wow
okay so actually I'm on step three okay
so look and we've got a fault no it goes
like this pull this back tuck this guy
I'm on to something
can we do something else no we're too
deep we yes we are oh now it's look like
it looks like that look I need your help
I can't get me to hog on the master you
say how did you do that to my eyes
revelon sir
they want you to basically I would have
never we would have been here all day
boom Wow for some reason my brain cannot
comprehend how you made the paper do it
do you see this they'll fold it in oh I
see why because it has to go like this
so you just overextended it
step 6 sweaty wait we need back I'm just
glad we got past open it flat what did
you do
whoa Wow it's very trippy would you do
would you pull her arms in you guys are
doing it ah oh this is actually really
cool is like fulfilling is and then you
fall this piece down
oh and then I think she's done I think I
think oh shut your mouth mouth Leah
[Music]
that's not it
now we're gonna test our functional art
salud just a little please I'm scared
I'm scared okay
[Music]
cool art teachers we did it good that
wasn't really hard how do you feel I
feel good I'm really proud of us like I
honestly thought I was gonna try to make
this and then just completely give up
doing it sober was definitely more
challenging I mean do I mean doing it
[Music]
[Music]